[Music]
our cooking confidence coach and anybody
is back in studio thanks to Chapman
Automotive the sponsors of this segment
and today we are learning how to make
year-round gazpacho I know you love
gazpachos you have to right it's right
in your alley right that is something
that is so fresh and so tasty but you
got to do it right and it takes three
minutes to make as long as here's the
tidbit make sure you chop everything up
just like I did just now for the show
okay okay so I have a passion to get
people to start cooking with appetizers
because they're quick and they help you
learn to cook you'll be healthier and
happier if you do so we're going to
start out with fresh tomatoes this is my
favorite tool that just sliced all these
fresh tomatoes in one swoop in one swoop
that's over so that's the first tidbit
the second tidbit is any recipe that
calls for tomato juice instead use V8
juice because V8 juice makes it richer a
little meatier it's just great and so
that's what we're going to add so here
we've got Tomatoes we have canned
tomatoes we drain them in case we run
out of um V8 juice then we're going to
put in
cucumber Peppers garlic
onion
jalapeno another tidbit make sure that
you don't let your hands touch that put
a glove on when you're slicing and lime
zest okay we're gonna give that a toss
everything is so fresh can you smell it
right yeah now in goes the salt and
pepper okay fresh squeezed lime juice oh
my gosh because everything is Salt Fat
acid here's more acid which is the apple
cider vinegar here you go with
Worcestershire sauce did I say that
right someone said to say what's this
here sauce what's this here sauce which
adds a lot of the salt believe it or not
because it's very salty and here's
another Nanny Bubby can't even say my
own name tidbit that I forgot in this
recipe I use smoked Tabasco sauce it's
smoky it's bold and it's Chipotle smoked
and it's great so about one and a half
teaspoons of that in there and then
smoked olive oil so we're going to put
that in and now very quickly in comes
four cups I know we're coming down to
the right okay so we're gonna mix it up
and then in order to add a little bit of
texture we're going to take half of it
Pour it in another Bowl keep that here I
will get this done I promise you one
more time okay we're gonna take the
immersion blender
[Applause]
and into because it just adds extra
texture okay and from there we put it
right into the bowl that looks amazing
Annie Bubby and if it's not juicy enough
add a little more V8 juice and here we
go right into the bowl with this and you
would add avocado
while you don't have the time to put in
but after the avocado you're going to
put a little bit of quesadillas right in
there and if you want to taste it you
can yeah we'll taste it we are going to
be marinated for about you could do it
overnight which is great it even tastes
better the next day perfect check out
Nanny Bubby's kitchen and Garden on
social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
Chapman Automotive for sponsoring this
segment this is delicious
save some for me Mercedes all right